now it seems only fitting that a
of this nature would begin with a panel
entitled Byzantine subjectivity and
modernity one that brings to the
forefront both the subject of Byzantium
as envisioned by modernity and the
subject of modernity as envisioned
through Byzantium it is this duel
positioning this Chi asmik turning back
and looking at one another that our two
following speakers bring us into the
question that bring into question bring
us into the question so forth by this
conference sorry our first speaker is
tortise papua new associate professor of
classics and director of the modern
Greek Studies program at brown
university professor papua new studied
Greek literature at the university of
athens in greece and byzantine
literature and culture at the university
of vienna where he earned his doctorate
in two thousand before joining browns
department of classics in january 2006
professor Papio a new top pros classical
Greek at the Catholic University of
America he has received research
fellowships from Dumbarton Oaks the
Center for Advanced Study at the
norwegian academy of science and letters
in oslo and the humboldt foundation at
the fiio universitate in berlin
professor of papua new has published
extensively in a variety of languages
some of his recent articles include
byzantine and her gaya and theories of
representation and michael pizzelles
rhetorical gender his forthcoming book
is entitled michael pizzelles rhetoric
and authorship in Byzantium to be
published by Cambridge University Press
and he has an additional forthcoming
volume entitled Michael pusillus on
literature and art co-edited with
Charles barber his paper today is titled
the history of autobiography & byzantine
literature please help me in welcoming
professor status fabiana well thank you
roland for the introduction and the
invitation to participate since my topic
is autobiography I think it's proper to
begin with a confession because I must
confess that though flattered I am a bit
puzzled by the fact that I'm the first
speak in this conference and especially
in the first panel of illustrious
speakers yet like a good Byzantine I'm
just accept my place in the prescribed
order of things
they prescribed taxis hoping that there
is some kind of divine reason behind it
the modern fate of Byzantine
autobiography maybe I can see maybe a
little more light is there a light here
okay all right that's better so the
modern fate of Byzantine autobiography
the expression as well as creation that
is of discursive subjectivity in
medieval Greek writing for which I would
like to make a case today is connected
with the trajectory of the culture we
have come to call centium in western
european historical consciousness this
consciousness had increasingly little
space from Byzantium caught as it was in
models of universal history that
privileged the Western European insider
the history graphical tradition that
addressed this insider to borrow a
scheme recently explored by Antonius
lyosha mixed narratives of decline that
followed a linear teleological time
frame with relatives of revival cyclical
time at utopian progress the former so
the Roman Empire in its medieval
continuations as the last and inferior
stage of a declining humanity only to be
saved by the eminent divine retribution
the scheme is nicely visualized here in
this late 18th century etching engraved
by tobias conrad lauter most famous for
his cartographic work and i'll show you
three examples here the Colossus
monarchy Cruz represents the statue from
The Book of Daniel and the sequence in
decline of the
various universal monarchies Byzantium
occupies the bottom right leg the
internet work of the unending divine
Kingdom is on the upper right of the
picture the narrative of revival and
progress promoted a different image here
visualized in another engraving designed
by Rubens and used for a book on
greco-roman antiquity published in 1645
time and death on the upper right throw
the empires of Rome Macedonian Persia
into the abyss from which mercury
revives proper greco-roman antiquity in
the form of statues and the slave that
delivers coins in this image that
breathes a self-confident Renaissance of
glorious antiquity Byzantium is entirely
absent as it is part of that medieval
version of the Roman world that is
tramped upon and rejected into darkness
of course it is true that at a closer
look Byzantium after the sack of
Constantinople in 1204 by the Crusaders
had a variety of transactor ease within
the consciousness of European maternity
to which I cannot to justice here
nevertheless the sedimented views of
history that I just described demanded
that largely speaking Byzantium
especially because it is essentially a
culture without a modern air a modern
national air that is would remain a
marginal word in Co gross to the core
the cultural mainstream there have been
some exceptions to this and parts of
European modernism to which this
conference is devoted is a case in point
but even in these exceptions that what
usually is appropriated is a Byzantium
that remains somewhat speechless without
signature abbreviated to a visual
vocabulary reconstructed by elements of
mosaics the icon painting and church
architecture the modern fate of
Byzantine discursive of the Byzantine
discursive tradition the other half of
the byzantine world of representation
accentuates even further the marginality
of Byzantium never
claimed as a national literature except
from its me I govern ocular production
visit the literature remains a fandom in
the modern world this is a literature
with no cannon we would be hard-pressed
to identify say a top 10 of Byzantine
literature and don't worry there will be
no quiz more importantly this is a
literature with no modern community with
a no modern community of readers to whom
it matters with the exception perhaps of
greek orthodox church goers who are
exposed to some byzantine texts though
again this is an abbreviated Byzantium
unsurprisingly the modernist literary
not visual art in modernist literary not
visual art Byzantine literature is
rarely if ever referenced and my
impression is that the few references
that do exist ekin faintly some of the
principal ways in which Byzantium is
rediscovered in modernism as an
expression of perhaps exotic or decadent
but also appealing formal other pneus
and this is substitute for a hidden
nostalgia for religious ritual a tool in
other words for modernism's or tensive
break from tradition and modern isms
uncanny yielding to quasi-religious
enchantment here is for example a poem
in the aftermath but still the tradition
of modernism that reflects but also
reflects this stereotypical approach to
the byzantine discursive art of
representation while the Empire went to
pot he amused himself extemporize
immoral highly moral I ambach sufficient
in rhythm this poem that caricatures a
Byzantine poets and which is followed by
another brief form in Odin's marginalia
that sites by name my cups a loss the
11th century Constantinople the North to
whom I will return also below modernism
has brought little change here Odin who
wrote this poem in the 1960s and echoes
and at the same time reduces a sentiment
already
for example kaveh fees a Byzantine
nobleman in exile composing verses or a
poem written almost a hundred years
earlier during the heart of the
symbolist movement by Paul Verlaine his
long war I am the Empire at the end of
the decadence composing lazy indolent
acrostic poems in a gilded style in
which the languor of the Sun dances
there is certainly more to discover in
the unwritten history of the peculiar
Pleasance of the Byzantine literary
tradition in the literary world of
modernity my concern however lights l
square against the backdrop of these
introductory observations I would like
to do two things first explore the
European reception of a particular
aspect of Byzantine literature namely
discourse in the first person singular
and then offer glimpses of an
alternative history of Byzantine
discursive subjectivity if one were to
open any recent volume on the history or
the of theories as well as discursive
practices of subjectivity and there are
several such books one would be
hard-pressed to discover any reference
to Byzantium and Byzantine authors in
this respect the historiography of
subjectivity literary subjectivity
especially has changed little since
enlightenment from its perspective
Byzantium is and remains a world of the
impersonal a world without sovereign
interrelating the individual subjects in
this dominant view the Byzantine self
works like the Byzantine artists in the
orientalizing gaze of Yeats for example
the painter the mosaic worker the worker
in gold and silver the illuminator of
sacred brooks were almost impersonal
almost without the consciousness of
individual design Yates wrote in his
autobiographical a vision there are two
remarkable exceptions to this view of
Byzantine self would that date to the
first half of the 20th
century and though both instances
confirm some anxieties eurocentric even
colonialist recurrent in the period they
are both worth examining in some detail
the 18th volume of the year nineteen
thirty two of the journal imago contains
a small surprise for the byzantine 'used
the journal which Sigmund Freud started
and directed from 1911 until the eve of
the Second World War in 1997 hosted
studies of psychoanalysis applied to
historical figures of the past here for
example is the beginning of the 1925
volume with an article by Freud himself
on the case of the devil's neurosis in
the 17th century on the Austrian painter
Christoph heitzman in the eighteenth
volume an reidel Medical presented a 30
page article devoted to the
autobiography of a Byzantine writer and
the title reads an oedipal complex in
the 11th century Michael celos del
medico provides a close reading of
celosa funeral raishin for his mother
here is a lost in a 12th century
miniature a text in which celos
constructed a high geographical portrait
of his mother and grave with lengthy
autobiographical digressions including
the description of some remarkable
dreams del medico acknowledges that the
name of celos will be unrecognizable to
most of the journals readers because he
writes unfortunately the entire
byzantine culture has been so much
neglected but the medical hopes to use
as he says this forgotten byzantine
writer in order to turn the attention of
westerners to the east where they might
discover and i quote the key to certain
features of the modern man's character
that primitive people cannot deliver the
article is at once remarkable and
disappointing remarkable for the
willingness to look beyond the
boundaries of what was considered the
Western European tradition for the
prehistory of modern sexual subjectivity
it is worth remembering the for example
that the successors of this kind of
enterprise were not so willing myself
calling he celebrated an unfinished
history of sexuality left the late
antique and medieval Greek tradition
entirely outside his purview and the
lack of knowledge of Greek could not be
an excuse in this case appealing I'll
also some of del medico sees readings as
I noted celos reports some remarkable
dreams that depart from usual dream
vocabulary of byzantine writers in one
of them he sees himself brought by
angels in front of a stony buyer barrier
which he then must pass on his own
brought through a naval he writes which
lay open in the form of an uneven circle
it's a loss than in the dream indeed
passes through as he says and finds
himself he so he passes through as the
stony opening he writes yields to him
like the softest flesh and then he finds
himself in a church in front of an icon
of the Virgin del medico as you might
expect reads here perhaps not
unjustifiably a suppressed sexual desire
the momentous entrance signifies a
sexual act which however according to
tell medical is immediately confronted
by the prohibition he writes then comes
the repression the icon of the mother of
god however unusual the article is also
disappointing in its circularity of
argument the Byzantine text is made to
fit the demands of a universalizing
discourse of the Freudian male self
inescapably fellow sufferers of a more
batteries and Tim or a more mattress and
Tim or Patrice
and is diagnosed with latent
homosexuality that explains his enormous
narcissism the loss is refashioned so as
to fit the anxieties of the male
modernist subject in other corners of
more or less contemporary German
intellectual writing bizant in this
course of the first person singular was
to find some more refined readers in
1904 a young man of Jewish descent in
his mid-20s by the name of Georg mesh
here in a photo taken about 30 years
later presented a three-volume work to
the prussian academy of berlin titled
the history of autobiography borrow
biography following the footsteps of his
teacher and father-in-law will William
dill tie but also influenced by German
philosophical tradition the trace its
roots roots back to get and Burkhardt
the yunk mesh devoted each volume 2
respectively greco-roman antiquity the
Middle Ages and modernity he read
closely as many texts that he could
identify autobiographical which he which
he used as documents of for the history
of the gradual and glorious process of
individuation as he called it the
humanities most important achievement
the slow but exciting discovery of
oneself the third volume of 1904
concluded nearly at the eve of modernism
and it with an aporia will there be miss
wrote a new autobiographical art more
art form where new forms of the creative
imagination will develop an art form he
continues comparable to the memoirs of
the late 19th century German writing
where and I quote again we sends the
great the creative power of the heroic
man of modern times mish who went on to
live for another 60 years living Brock
ball through both
world wars and the troubling but
exciting period between them did not
continue his work in search of an answer
to this question instead he spent almost
his entire career as a university
professor than an exile intellectual in
England and then again a professor in
getting in here is a photo taken later
late in his life so he spent his life
expanding his original three-volume work
in order to write a comprehensive and
thorough history of autobiography which
included not only works of ancient Greek
Latin and other Western European
languages but also arabic and Byzantine
Greek the work was recently revised and
expanded form right after the Second
World War and is now available in 8
massive volumes of three hundred and
eighty-three thousand excuse me 885
pages here's a photo just to give you a
sense of size of size of just two of
these eight volumes the work is
monumental in every respect no one would
repeat something even close to this
after him and modern historians of
autobiography are often too quick to
dismiss it all the while expressing
their all at the achievement the
dismissal derives from the fact that
this history of autobiography or rather
of universal human self consciousness
has mesh so it turns out to be a
prehistory of gradual and glorious
emergence visualized nicely in the cover
of a recent RIA dition of a very
specific type of subjectivity modern
secular European in the German and a my
dad male subjectivity or even we might
playfully say Misha's own subjectivity
the last chapter of the original work is
devoted to his father-in-law tilt I as
one might expect Byzantine writer
writing the
did indeed include did not fare all that
well in his teleological scheme the
Byzantines do one must admit a little
better than say in hegel's earlier
account of Byzantium as a world with no
greatness in thoughts deeds and
individuals this is a quote from Hagel's
influential philosophy of history that
follows a similar teleological pattern
so in context to that approach mesh does
note the achievements of byzantine
writers like scenarios of tyranny and
gregory of nazianzus and the early
byzantine authors committee regards as
precursors to Augustine and he also does
spend 70 pages on michelson laws and
several more pages on a few other late
late byzantine authors yet mish cannot
but complain for example that senescence
does not actually reach freedom I quote
in his self expression similarly mrs.
almost surprised to discover in gregory
of nazianzus expressions that show that
he was conscious of the subjective
character of his poetry as for the later
more properly Byzantines a loss in mrs.
account he discovers in him a
personality that is unworthy of or even
stands against the humane in the
humanistic tradition classical tradition
that he revives the loss in mrs. in the
account of mesh stone stands apart in
sharp distance from the free man who
desires truth and clarity VAR height on
Clare height the Byzantine
autobiographical self that is though it
must be included for the sake of
scientific history syst
comprehensiveness it cannot at the same
time satisfy the linear narrative of the
emergence of European subjectivity it
remains an outsider but we would be
mistaken to bypass so easily
the painstaking reading of the sources
of mesh his pioneering and with all its
erroneous assumptions scrupulous
examination of autobiographical text
from a variety of linguistic traditions
that remained and I believe
unfortunately without following or
influence no other modern European
writer with the exception of his
Antinous he spent such time and energy
on considering even the possibility that
the story worth telling exists regarding
the Byzantine discourse in the first
person singular compare for example the
work of mesh with Eric our parks mimesis
the other similarly monumental in its
vision but also in this case influence
work a work that was devoted to a
universal history of European of the
European literary tradition from
antiquity to modernity a history of the
representation of reality in literature
the similarities between the two works
are striking Auerbach who later became
professor of Romance philology here at
Yale completed like mesh his work in
exile in Istanbul during the Second
World War and like mesh he saw in
Sookie's work as a defence of the values
of humanism so meticulously shattered by
the horrors of Nazism like mesh to our
buck told through the history of mimesis
a history of the secular free autonomous
individual subject in European writing
and it is interesting that in the recent
anniversary edition prefaced by Edward
side a modernist painting is chosen max
beckmann's departure yet unlike mesh
Auerbach spends no time to the post
classical Greek tradition the road from
Homer leads unidirectionally to Western
European writing Katrien d'etre Dante
Shakespeare a typically Western canon by
not looking at all like misty that the
post classical Greek
addition however and opportunities
perhaps missed for our power back
writing in Istanbul to discuss for
example the most comprehensive in my
view and I do not say this lightly
theoretician of mimesis in the
pre-modern philosophical tradition I
refer to pro plus a constant napolitan
who led the philosophy the platonic
philosophical school in Athens in the
mid 5th century CE and who exerted great
influence also in the west through the
works of an unlikely student another
byzantine writer the Christian
theologian known as turn issues the
Areopagus therefore mesh even just for
his obsessive devotion to a universal
history of autobiography deserves
admiration it is an irony of history
that he never managed to revise the
third volume of his original work of the
eight final volumes that is one and a
half are devoted to antiquity six and
half to the post classical and medieval
literature's and only one the slimmest
are never revised to modernity mesh who
began his career as a firm at fervent
advocate of modernity the kind of modern
self-confidence from which modernism
almost desperately wished to flee Mitch
who experienced the unforgiving
malicious side of that modernity became
in the end almost unwittingly a
medievalist here you have a man who
seems to remain death to the challenges
of modernism as well as speechless to
the horrors of modernity his desire for
new forms of self-expression posed as a
question in 1904 remains chillingly
unanswered the clock for him seems to
have stopped in the early 20th century
and soulless can be found only in the
close readings of the distant medieval
authors or his miss perhaps another
version of modern indeed modernist
appropriation of medieval and that also
Byzantine aesthetics I mean that the
attempt to construct a comprehensive
view of human history of the unified
human self or beginning to
present makes the sister of mesh the
last Universal Chronicle a discursive
form first cultivated to obsessive
perfection by visiting authors and
imitated in a variety of linguistic of
neighboring linguistic traditions the
form that lies behind both laughter's
statue of Daniel with which I began and
its declining sequence of kingdoms all
visualized as one man with which and
Misha's own progressive self discovery
of the European man at this point I
would like to leave mish and modern
reception history aside and turn for the
third and last part of my paper to some
exploratory remarks of Byzantine
discursive subjectivity it is hopefully
clear that by what i have said thus far
that i regard the notion that
subjectivity is invented in this or that
period of western european history as a
modern history graphical myth driven by
ideological prerogatives it is i believe
self-evident that neither the
consciousness of ins of oneself north
IRA's of self nor a discourse and
representation of subjectivity are
privileges of the of this or that
society or social group epi's antinous
could for instance say without sounding
too defensive that visiting philosophers
expanding on earlier traditions
developed a sophisticated theoretical
language of subjectivity the notion of
personal opposed disease or personal
personhood for example in gregory of
nazianzus gregory of nyssa or maximus
the confessor in notion that today is
discussed primarily by almost only by
patristic scholars and orthodox
theologians it's part of a remarkable
attempt to articulate the subjectivity
that accommodates both relationality and
autonomy the examples could go on my
concern however is to point some of the
particularities of the byzantine of
byzantine approaches to discursive
subjectivity I could begin with
the example of the notion of apostasy is
just mentioned in order to say that
Byzantine writers show some reluctance
to transfer the sophisticated vocabulary
they create regarding the subjectivity
of divine personhood to human subjects
for human self food that is they
continue to employ though again with
expansions and variations the
philosophical discourse of Plato and
Aristotle which stressed a fragmented
and layered self from matter and body to
the soul and mind this disparity in
approach has much to do with the fact
that Byzantine writers similarly to
similarly to but more pointed pointedly
than visiting artists operated with a
diverse and often contradictory series
of inherited vocabularies and registers
of this course bodies of language text
forms and knowledge Byzantine writers
were trained to switch between these
registers in almost imperceptible ways
that cannot satisfy the double impulse
of modern historiography for to identify
coherent systems of thought and linear
histories of form the Byzantine written
tradition is a hybrid tradition and
simultaneously a fragmented one it is
also a world where precisely tradition
and the authority of convention provide
the mask of innovation originality and
why not individuality the culture of
Byzantine representation is a culture in
which tradition is the tool for becoming
oneself perhaps in the exact opposite
ways to modernism if you will allow me
this irreverent statement Byzantium is a
representational culture that shouts
convention while silently creating minut
forms of avant-garde the
autobiographical text the Byzantine
discourse in the first person singular
is no exception to this within the
Byzantine rhetorical tradition
literary tradition that came to dominate
byzantine performance in book culture we
encounter authors who place themselves
their lives and emotions at the
forefront of the text primarily in two
specific modes of writing that they
inherited from antiquity the speech of
self-defense Socrates apology provided
one of the models for this and later
writing which Byzantines defined is the
process of imprinting mirroring imaging
creating an icon and corn of the
writer's soul bound by this by this
Greek rhetorical tradition and its
unveiling conservatism itself an impulse
that infused Greek writings in its since
its own period of colonial expansion in
the four centuries BC medieval Greek
writers for instance never create a
literature of confession that in Latin
and then Western European tradition
found its most eloquent representative
in Augustine for Byzantines the model of
self representational rhetoric is an
author already mentioned and examined by
mesh that is gregory of nazianzus here
in a 12 century reported from one of the
several lumen ated manuscripts that
contain his works this canonical figure
of the Byzantine Christian dogma and
learning happened to be also one of the
most self self-referential writers of
the Greek tradition a member of the
rising Christian aristocracy of the late
Roman world a professional writer made
bishop Gregory found in constant found
himself in constant need of redefinition
self-definition in direct competition
with others to whom he addressed a
carefully fashion self-portrait let me
give you a very very small taste of
Gregory's first person speech from his
self defense his apology Ticos while
defending his devotion to private
contemplation as opposed to public
action Gregory writes and I quote
nothing seemed to me to be comparable to
shouting shouting with the senses and
going beyond flesh in the world turning
inside myself living beyond the visible
and continually bearing in myself God's
reflections
both being and always becoming truly a
spotless mirror of God one may talk
about the philosophical notions of
subjectivity upon which this mini
self-portrait is predicated the
combination of being and becoming for
instance is a bold philosophical move if
set in comparison to the earlier
tradition what interests me here however
is the aesthetics of this rhetorical
self-portrait if one looks closely one
realizes that there that these are not
Gregory's own words to some extent for
example when he claims to be a spotless
mirror of God he adopts an Old Testament
metaphor that interpreters of the Bible
read this expressive of Christ that
spotless mirror of the Father
simultaneously Gregory's phrase shutting
the census is lifted verbatim from an
inferential essay by the New Platonist
petrino's titled on beauty in which
platanos urged his readers to avoid the
deceptive simulacra offered by the
senses and the dangerous self mirroring
of narcissus but instead to focus on the
inner self Gregory dades assumes the
voice of biblical as well as platonic
discourse which he now abuses and speaks
in the first person singular the text
expresses the desire which then performs
gradually becomes himself through the
ideal models provided by tradition the
passage is typical to speak of oneself
in the Byzantine tradition was to set
oneself in a hierarchical relationship
in which the personal I merges with the
exemplary I to pursue it's it's a
rhetoric which positions as well as
expresses the individual self with and
through the ideal models provided
through normative others there are
visual counterparts it seems to me to
this aesthetics while we do not have as
far as I know any Byzantine self
portraits in the narrow sense of the of
the word of an artist who paints himself
we do have self portraits in a more
flexible sense of portraits where the
represented figure was or must have been
to some extent involved
in the production of his or her image
I'm referring for example to the
so-called donor portraits here is an
early example in the medium of icon
painting that you again on earlier
visual art the viewers gaze is first
directed to the large figure on the in
the center the st. identified as such by
an inscription bearing a halo looking
directly at you at the left corner of
the panel the painter has added another
figure that also carries a name and is
most likely the person who commissioned
the work the icon this is I would argue
the closest we get to a Byzantine visual
self-portrait its aesthetics are similar
to those of Gregory the self is set in a
hierarchical relationship to a normative
as well as protective other that both
subjects the self the gesture of
kneeling the size of the figure suggests
as much as well as however subjective
faiz the small Nicholas who in the frame
of the icon is allowed to occupy an
ultimately exceptional position next to
and in contact with the Saint
transcending the boundaries of the human
condition the effect of business itself
representational aesthetics is thus
double on the one hand the self retreats
submits surrenders on the other one
discovers creates performs oneself in
the act of submission let me conclude
with Byzantine autobiography the eleven
hundred years of Byzantine writing have
an intriguing series of discursive self
portraits to offer I have only shown you
a tiny brief example from the dominating
voice of Gregory to display some of the
limitations but also the possibilities
what I hope is clear is that none of
these pro portraits can easily be mapped
in histories that seek to identify
linear narratives of progress or decline
or easily recovered in greedy nostalgic
gestures of appropriation for Byzantine
authors
speak to us from behind the series of
masks which in which perhaps
paradoxically they sought a true genuine
voice with which to speak about
themselves a voice with which to express
the I that speaks under the specific
angle of its existence to use the words
of the poet who articulated most
eloquently the end of modernity and
modernism alike thank you